hey everyone it's Jessie and today is
the last day that I will be working on
this project so so far for all of my
streams for free code camp I've been
working on this one project this react
site and today's the last day so I'm
really excited I'm excited to move on to
my next project I'm not actually
entirely sure what my next project will
be there's a couple of different options
my boss is still on his honeymoon I
think he gets back today
she might be um by now I'm not sure but
he'll be in tomorrow and then we'll
we'll decide together what my next
project will be but there's a good
chance it'll be another react another
react site so before I get started today
I just want to give a birthday shout out
to a friend of mine
Zach Levin Dorf who's I hope he doesn't
mind me giving this shout out like this
but I just wanted to mention him on on
this stream because if it wasn't for him
I probably would not be here doing this
stream like I wouldn't be a developer at
all so I don't know maybe five years ago
or so something like like that I really
needed a job and I was about to take a
job that I didn't even really want to do
but it was just going to be something to
pay the bills and he offered me a job
doing basically subcontracting work for
him and he had like a media marketing
company and
he I had known him before and I had
known his family so he knew that I was a
decent guy and so he gave me a chance
even though I hadn't built any websites
for a really long time
and he actually would would tell me like
hey I'll pay you for so many hours just
go learn how to do this and I'll pay you
for it which was really cool because I
really you know I had a few kids at the
time and I really needed the money and I
didn't have a lot of a lot of time to go
and learn on my own I needed to be
working so that really helped so for a
few years I did a lot of work with him
and anyway so I'm not sure if he's gonna
watch or not I told him I was gonna give
him a shout-out so I just wanted to to
tell him happy birthday and just let
everybody know how important it is he
was kind of like a mentor to me at a
time when I was just starting out and
not really sure what I wanted to do so
if you have a chance to do something
like that for someone definitely do that
it doesn't have to be I guess like an
official mentor like you know he he
wasn't my mentor officially Wicker we
worked together but he taught me a lot
about freelancing in general you know
how to handle clients and contracts and
billing and you know a lot of things
like that a lot about WordPress and
about search engine optimization and and
he was he's a really good designer as
well so he taught me a lot about design
and yes that was that was cool we had we
spent we spent a lot of time we would
just stay up all night and work on build
websites and those were some of the best
learning experiences you know because we
would take a break and get something to
eat
and just and talk for awhile in between
coding sessions and that was really
important for me when I was just
starting out so if you ever have a
chance to do that with somebody that's
just starting out
it'll definitely make a big difference
to them it might not might not be that
big of a deal to you it might not be
that hard for you to do but it can make
a big impact on someone so I hope that I
can have that same impact on somebody
one day and kind of pay it forward but
I'm gonna check the live chat yeah
actually
Patrick is asking what happened to the
viewer count yeah this is really weird
so usually at the beginning of the
streams the analytics there's some lag
time or something so it shows like zero
viewers for a minute or so but actually
this is really this is really odd
because it's showing three viewers and
it should have already refreshed so
anyway yeah Patrick I don't know what
happened the last time something like
this happened I didn't realize it but I
think I was streaming during like
Facebook's livestream of of one of their
conferences so maybe maybe there's
something happening that I'm missing I
don't really know but I did let me
double check I usually put the link on
on Twitter yeah I did at 2:00 p.m.
Eastern time I put the link on Twitter I
put the right time okay did everything I
the the tweet has it hasn't gone out to
that many people but yeah I did
everything right I mean I did send it
out you know less than an hour ago but
yeah I don't really know what's what's
going on but it's fine with me I still
need to do the work anyway so I mean I
hope I didn't do anything wrong and
people are like I hope people aren't
getting blocked out of seeing this but
let me I guess really quickly I'm going
to go on another browser and try to to
watch the stream I should be able to
just maybe do an incognito window and
let's see
all right so I'm gonna go on my other
screen I'm going to freak out camp yeah
it does say live now free code camp I'm
gonna try to click it okay cool I was
able to get in and watch so but it does
say yeah there's only six people
watching that's crazy
alright well anyway you know actually
the the title that I gave the video was
not really enticing I just said it was
finishing my react site so maybe people
aren't really interested in seeing me
finish this usually I'm more a more
descriptive title so maybe maybe that's
why or maybe there's something else live
that's really important I mean did
something crazy happen on the news and
I'm just not aware of it I don't know
anyway I'm gonna go ahead and get
started
so as the title says I am just trying to
finish up the site today so I'm gonna
show you here's my Trello board and the
link to this is in the description so in
case you really do want to check out the
board it's it's public also like I did
yesterday to start out with if you're
interested in seeing my facial
expressions as I code and seeing a
little bit of what my office looks like
you can check me out on on Instagram on
my phone I'm live-streaming
on Instagram the the view like looking
right at my face as I as I code so the
link to my Instagram is also in the in
the description but as you can see right
now I'm working on this JW player so I
had changed from a YouTube embed and
this was over the weekend I think I
changed from a YouTube embed to JW
player embed the problem was the normal
embed that that's a script tag it loads
the first time you load the home page
but then after that when you use the
client-side routing it doesn't load so
there's there's not really anything like
I can
initialize it and component did mount or
anything as far as I know I had thought
about maybe trying to do something like
that but I found a plugin I'm sorry like
a react component for JW player and I
set it up I had a little bit of trouble
getting the right info but Sebastian is
usually in the in the live streams
he had mentioned like why don't I just
check out the the actual JavaScript file
that I was that I was pulling in from
the normal embed and if I scroll down to
the bottom there was a bunch of info
there so using that info and then
rereading the documentation on the on
the component I was able to get it
working the problem is it's not
displaying like the full width of the
screen like the other one was like I
wanted it to so I need to figure out
what's going on right now I'm just kind
of comparing the CSS for the old layouts
doing it in the new way and trying to
match it up is exactly is it because I
can I thought I had it messed up exactly
but it's still not working so I'm gonna
give it maybe just one more Pomodoro
session and if I can't get it done then
I'm gonna go with Plan B which is I'm
not gonna use client-side routing for
when people go to the home page I really
don't want to do that because then I'm
losing a lot of the advantages of you
know the speed of being able to just do
the client-side routing but I don't
really have time right now
to spend a whole lot of time on this and
it it just needs to be done so that's
the plan hopefully I can get it working
though I really don't want to go with
with Plan B and disable that client-side
routing and what I mean by that is it's
gonna actually refresh the page and so
that way the video will play again
because it'll have a full page refresh
and as you
can see I have basically this is it this
is all that really needs done and
actually everything on this list doesn't
absolutely need to be done so some of
the things I just really want to get
done like we had the geolocation to sort
events by distance this was never
something that was asked for on the site
this was just something that I thought
was a really obvious feature that should
be on the site so if I can't get to this
this art the geolocation already works I
just need to have some indication in the
user interface that you can do that
because right now there's there's no
indication at all that you can click on
distance and sort by distance so I'm
sorry click on location and sort by
distance in the same way with the tables
you can sort things in the tables by
clicking on the table headers but
there's no indication that you can do
that so right now it's more of like an
easter egg on the site so if I need to I
can put off some of these probably in a
few months I'll be able to come back and
work on some of these things again but
for now probably have looks like four
four and a half Pomodoro sessions
according to my estimates that I should
be able to get this done so it might
take more or less depending on how
accurate my estimates are and then
that's in addition not including this
other Pomodoro session so I'm guessing
probably like 6:00 to probably about six
sessions that's a 25 minutes a session
with some breaks in between that's about
three hours since I'll be streaming for
a lot of that time I'm gonna say
probably four hours of work since I
usually have questions and things
although if I continue to only have six
viewers there probably won't be that
many questions so though I could see
Alberto is in the stream hey Alberto
glad that you could you could join us
okay this reminds me when I first
started streaming and I would have is
actually worse when I first started
sometimes I'd be no one watching or just
one person watching so maybe I'll get
more done since I won't have as much
activity in the stream I am a little bit
nervous that like some terrible thing
happened and everybody's watching the
news and I don't know about it but I
would think my co-workers would let me
know like I'd be getting something my
phone would be buzzing and with with
news updates I suppose but it is a
little weird alright so let's go with
this oh I did want to say to my my very
first video for free code camp now has
over 10,000 views so it's really excited
about that I noticed yesterday that it
had I hadn't checked the view count in a
long time and I noticed that I was I
needed less than 50 views to get to
10,000 so I was excited so I kept kept
watching it so this morning when I
checked it I had I think ten thousand
and three views so that was really cool
so thanks everyone for for watching and
everybody that that viewed it and it has
a bunch of thumbs up mostly thumbs up
not too many thumbs down so that's
really really cool
let's let me bring over let me start my
my Pomodoro timer so let's pull I'll
pull this over here and I guess here's
what I'm going to do for right now I'm
gonna bring over dev tools for both
versions so on on the left hand side
this is the new way that I'm embedding
using the JW player react component and
this is the older way using just this
script tag so let me let me know if this
font size is too small it looks a bit
small but since I'm I don't want to make
it too big because I need to be able to
see both these things so just let me
know I I could probably make it a little
bit bigger and it'll still work but
really what I want to do is I'm gonna
look at this this is the first component
that really gets
it gets added dynamically alright so
that's the one that I want to compare
because everything else that's
containing it is exactly the same
because these are components that I have
direct control over so let's look at
this top level component I think this is
all we'll have to to edit potentially
maybe if if I get these exactly the same
in terms of their CSS properties and it
still doesn't work I'll have to dig down
in farther and see that maybe some
something down in here you know it looks
the same right now actually I may have
just figured it out just kind of
inadvertently what is this JW aspect
JW aspect all right let me check a
little bit excited I think I may have
just figured this out so let me all
right so with height:auto that's what it
needs to be let's set this to
display:block and we need this padding
top
we need 50 6.25% oh man
that works awesome let me pull this over
really quick all right so it worked
before I just saw nothing and ice that's
really awesome I think I want to I want
to see if there are some options for me
to take take away this I don't need that
in there and let's see what happens ok
cool the controls come up great oh man
what what good luck the fact I wasn't
even gonna dig down in there and check
it out but that was it it was the very
first thing I looked at ok so I need to
probably the best way to do this is just
in my in my CSS file I'm just going to
add this I'm gonna target this class J
to the aspect I just want to make sure
really quickly that that same class
isn't used I don't see it being used
yeah that was good okay so I think if I
just started getting this JW aspect
class and actually let me just I'm just
gonna copy that I'm gonna set it to
display:block and then I'm going to add
this padding and that should be it that
should fix it so I had to comment I hate
to use important too often but I I had
to override it cuz there's there may be
some way for me to change that through
the through the react component there
probably is some way but at this point
you know this is this will work so I'm
just gonna go with that and the odds of
me actually having to use this component
and future projects are really small so
I just don't really want to dig that
deep into it to learn it later on if I
need it then that's fine I'll you know
maybe I will dig deeper but for now I
don't want to be here all night working
on this so let's try it out I'm gonna
save that and then I have to do after
you hard refresh cuz the hot like reload
doesn't work with my stylesheet hey
zanna's here hey how's it going
did I start early Oh actually you know
what I think I did I think I know what I
did let me go into my settings really
quickly here no I didn't it is right
today at 2:00 p.m. I thought that I
accidentally set it for 2:00 a.m.
instead of 2:00 p.m. but I didn't it it
is 2:00 p.m. and I'm pretty sure that I
did set it to promote it from one of my
channel page for me yeah I did the
settings right for a second uh-huh
that's odd I did just get a notification
on my phone from free code camp because
I'm logged in on my personal account on
my phone yeah then I didn't get the
notification I got was from one of those
videos and I did not get a notification
about my livestream on my phone that's
odd
so there's there's actually a decent
amount of activity on Twitter of people
liking and retweeting the the link that
I shared on Twitter for this but hmm oh
well I'm not not too worried about it I
mean if we get if nobody watches for
like a week in a row then maybe I'll
worry a little bit but for now I think
it's okay
okay yeah maybe it's just a weird thing
with the notifications I didn't realize
that many people relied on the
notifications from YouTube so I don't
think I can make it notification go out
let me check the settings just really
quickly broadcast alert yeah all the
broadcast alert options are like
technical difficulties or delays or
something like that so I don't want to
send one of those cuz that's not really
accurate alright so
let's see I'm checking out the live chat
quickly Emilia lass is that scrolling
effect part of react
it is like extra smooth which scrolling
effect just the normal scroll or like
this this effect if you're talking about
this navigation effect this is from it's
not part of react this is like a custom
it's just a little bit of JavaScript
that does that so I think it's in I have
Jess yeah this stick the sticky nav
function so if you check out the the git
repo the link to that's in the
description and look in the app j/s file
check out the function sticky enough and
it's just a modified version of so mark
synth did this on code pen and so I just
modified it for for this use case and
it's it's really short like you can see
not very many lines at all and it's a
nice effect so but I'm not even sure
that you're talking about let's see if
Patrick said you that his YouTube
notifications have been all screwed up
for all the channels for at least a week
said the notifications end up being
delayed
Amelia said got the same notifications
so maybe for these some people the
notifications are just messed up the
scroll okay so Amelia was saying the
scroll for this video okay so that was
that was what wooden Atia was talking
about cool yeah the it's actually a cool
effect what happens is there are two
knives so this this nav gets cloned so
there are actually two completely
different elements so the one stays with
its normal position and then the other
one once you get to a certain point the
other one goes with this position would
be position fixed so I mean you can
check it out there's actually some
decent commenting and that's when this
is from mark mark self put in the
comments and I left them in there so if
you've watched me you know I'm not great
with commenting I'm gonna try to get
better and upcoming projects but it
should be pretty pretty easy to work out
if you're familiar with jQuery then you
should be able to work out what's going
on okay
so we've added this
it wasn't refreshing can anybody guess
why it wasn't refreshing it's still my
dev server so I tried a little bit to
get my dev server to work so I went in
and remove like the the files that video
all had said to try to remove and that
didn't do anything but I didn't go so
far as to clone the repo into a
different folder just I was just working
on other things and that did not work
let me see what happened here
all right I might have to put some
importance in there let's see what
happened
well yep I just I even need to make this
more specific or I'll pray I'll just
make it more specific
so let's add this in actually that's
yeah it's I need to do this okay now go
to refresh yeah there we go alright so
you can see I refreshed it everything
looks good
last thing I need to do I mean probably
should test it it was it was pretty good
last thing I want to do is get rid of
this so I'm gonna have to go to the
documentation to have up on my other
screen so I'll bring it over here and I
have it a bit zoomed in I make it a bit
smaller so there's a bunch of options so
let's see they're probably already an
option
maybe there's not
I figured there would be an option to
hide the name of the video maybe run
through it again
all right yeah so my next idea then is
figure out what what part of this
controls like what element displays this
and then maybe I can just get rid of it
with CSS title yes
all right so that works so we're just
gonna get this JW title and we're gonna
set it to display:none I'm gonna do that
right in our CSS file so I'm just gonna
copy this and get rid of this and I
think it was called
yeah JW title that was pretty
straightforward so I'm going to save
that and let's refresh to make sure that
it's working all right
awesome that works all right so that
looks exactly the same as the other one
did and if we use our client-side
routing it should still work so I've
gone to the bout now I'm gonna go back
no page refresh and we still have our
video awesome and let me check my great
so even with me taking a little break to
check the live chat that still didn't
even take one Pomodoro session so we're
ahead of schedule now
so that really only took half I can get
rid of these great move that's it done
all right now let's figure out out of
these what what's the most important I'm
gonna move these to the bottom this geo
locations
what else the filters here because you
know like I said these were things that
I thought would be useful they're not
really what what anyone's expecting for
the site this can go down here too
yeah I think maybe my boss had asked for
this a long time ago so this is gonna be
easy to put it I'll put this on the
bottom I'm not really sure linked to
directions yeah I'm not even really sure
what I'm supposed to link to I have to
go back through my emails and stuff to
figure that out so we'll just leave that
on the bottom for now too and anything
that has like the categories and tags
I'm gonna move this down because right
now there's definitely not enough enough
posts to warrant having categories and
tags so if I don't get that in I think
it'll be alright because I think even in
a few months there's still not really
going to be that much on here to warrant
this because that you know they have the
same staff that's going to be updating
this site it's also going to be doing
things for the learning management
system and that actually did launch on
Saturday
like it was supposed to I'm assuming I
didn't I didn't hear anything to the
contrary so that did launch
someone else had had joined in the
livestream on Instagram so I didn't
notice that I want to try to notice when
somebody comes in on Instagram just to
let them know what's up because
otherwise people might not they're just
gonna see my face with headphones on and
I'm just talking to no one so that might
look a little bit weird I'm talking
about things they can't see I wish there
was a way to like have a message up on
the screen on Instagram just so I could
let people know like hey I'm doing this
live stream on YouTube if you want to
see the code but as far as I know
there's not a way to do that alright so
basically from here down from here down
don't have to worry about it
all so yeah this is gonna go way at the
bottom alright because I think this is
another thing that I thought would be
useful to have the link in the footer so
if it doesn't get down nobody's gonna
miss it add image to courses page okay
yeah I'll leave that I'm just gonna move
it down a bit because all these are go
together
alright so right now the news page is
not there's no link to the news page you
would have to type in the URL this would
be like khattak addicts column slash
news you can get to the news page like
that so we're gonna check out the news
page right now just to get you an idea
of what's what still needs done I'm it
looked at it in a little while okay so
like is on the list we need to find an
image edit the image so that it'll fit
in this space I think I need something
that's 2,000 pixels wide I can't
remember the height off the hook it up
so we'll find the image will edit the
image we'll put it in here we have
already our titles
that are getting pulled in and I guess I
don't have
okay I'll see all right so I had had the
idea of making the posts setting it so
that you could have a post that only
appeared on the home page and didn't
show up in the news page and that was
because some of these posts only just
link somewhere else in the site and they
just have a short sentence saying what
it does so I didn't think it would even
be worth it to have them show up here
and then when you click on it it would
go you know to a full page like this but
then nothing would be displayed or maybe
just one sentence now the problem with
that is nothing will really show up at
all and this was the whole reason we
never shared the news page before I'm
like I'm a little hesitant to even make
this news page live because we still
don't have anything here I know there
was some content all right we're gonna
do the work to get this news page ready
but if I can't find some good content to
go in here then maybe I'll maybe I'll
wait
I could always put something in there
that would check to see how many posts
are available and maybe change this link
so that when we do get posts later on
it'll automatically change and link to
the right page and then that way I don't
have to come in and edit it
I'm not sure it happened there
okay let me
I'm going to commit what we did with the
with the video use
okay all right hey we're up to nine
viewers now so we're getting up there
it looks like and Tawana is asking it
other videos at the beginning the
projects and Zanna yes there's a thanks
thanks for answering Zanna yeah check
out there are also a few videos of the
very beginning the project are on my
youtube channel in the link to that is
it's also in the description for this
video on I see Amelia Amelia just
answered that as well so once again I
forgot to look down and see so thanks
Amelia yeah
all right so yeah Zanna said it's the
feeling when one moves one card to to
the done yeah that's a good feeling to
move it over to done just look at this
doesn't it sleep you get to the end of
the project that looks amazing like this
is all that's left to do I mean I know I
have all this stuff that's like if I had
a lot of time I would do this but
ignoring this for a minute it's just
really cool it feels really good I mean
look at all this stuff in the done
column just really cool to have all that
I mean look that's you know over well
over 200 Pomodoro sessions completed
really cool that feels great all right
well let's just start let's start
getting these done so everything that
has to do with music it's ticking and
yeah are we don't I'm not gonna change
that yet and so we have this finished
and yeah so we'll do this then we'll
move on to this we'll see how much time
we have and go from there and let me try
to keep accurate estimates of my time so
I'm currently closing in on a hundred
and fifty hours of development time for
this that's a kind of a rough estimate I
usually underestimate a bit because that
doesn't include any meetings phone calls
or emails about this which there were a
lot so I think this is gonna end up
including all the meetings and
everything this is probably going to end
up being close to 200 hours of
development time for this Patrick asked
what Chrome extension I'm using for the
Trello thing and I always forget what it
is let me look actually is it this one
yeah okay so it's scrum for Trello so
that's the
so that's scrum SCR um Patrick I'm sure
you know what scrum is but in case
somebody's watching it's not familiar
with scrum it SCR um for Trello all
right let me get my my timer went off so
since there's not a lot going on in the
live chat right now although now we're
up to eleven viewers so we're getting
not nearly as many as we normally have
but we're getting there
let's see also just a heads up if you
see any if if you happen to watch the
Instagram thing although no I don't
think anyone right now and you see
somebody behind me my co-workers were
plotting to to get on YouTube or
Instagram or something by sneaking in
and and looking they're gonna have a
hard time though because I did lock my
doors so but that was their plot alright
so let's start up another Pomodoro
session let's grab an image for this I
need to find I think I have I don't
remember where I have all the images I
think they're my Google Drive
and actually I did I got an SVG version
of the logo as well that if we have time
I'm gonna put in there so John Hanson
who's often in the live chat converted
the the loge of this logo into an SVG
right now it's a ping I think so he sent
me that and I'm going to while I'm in my
Google Drive I'm just gonna download
that as well
since we might be using it Knox Aven I
haven't really even had a chance to
check it out yet but I'm a big fan of
SVG's whenever I can use them I think it
will end up looking that I don't know
how it looks on your screen but on my
screen this just does not look crisp at
all until i if i zoom in like this it
looks kind of crisp but it's just it
doesn't look great so what did you off
to check the file sizes and everything
I'm pretty sure the SVG will end up
being smaller but we'll we'll check that
out in a minute right now I need to find
hopefully I can find the so I'll bring
it over on this screen when I find it
just in case I have a lot of stuff from
clients in my drive so I don't want to
accidentally show anything from clients
that I shouldn't on YouTube
that's what my my son always asked if he
can like play video games on my
computers and stuff when I'm when I'm
logged in and I always saw him like you
can you can't like you could destroy so
many people's websites if you got on my
computer so especially I have a lot of
things in LastPass so you know he
wouldn't necessarily have to know the
passwords with LastPass if he could
figure out how to fill in everything
with like he's only seven so but he got
to be careful about that let me see
so I think I found the right folder all
right I did so let me bring this over
and let's check out some of these images
all right let me see how can i I'll zoom
in a bit so what page this is the news
page I'll say right away this image they
didn't like this image before the people
in charge the catechetical Institute as
there's like a header image because I
don't know because some of the stuff was
out they just didn't like that some
things were out of focus on other things
weren't out of focus which I don't
really know we could do anything about
that like obviously you can't have the
entire picture in focus if it's you know
things are in the background also
depending on the screen dimensions some
people's you know their heads will get
will won't be visible so they didn't
like that as well so I think anything
with people it's probably out so we just
need to look at some of these shots of
campus so that limits us to these and
some of them have already been used
you see also things like this that have
an obvious focus they're probably going
to be out of the question because once
again if part of it gets cut off that
they don't like that so like this isn't
gonna work
say I'm a bit limited
actually I wonder about this one I don't
think we've used this one
let me check quickly see if we've used
this one
that looks decent I know they really
want to use pictures of campus because
the people that are going to be using
their learning management system will
most likely not visit campus so they
want to give them a feeling of that this
really is attached to a physical campus
and not like it online only school
that's that's how they explain their
desire to have lots of the images of
campus Timmy I'm gonna go through
quickly and just make sure we're not
using how we are using it shoot okay so
using that this is different but it
really looks the same let me see if we
were using this I think we are let's
check it out
yep we're using that one too maybe not
that one but it looks pretty close it's
gonna settle think it's the same one no
it's not the same one unless there's
things getting cut off on the size oh
maybe it is the same one yeah okay
yeah that is the same one
I think we're using this one too let me
check the courses events
resources to say
yep that's it
I've already already picked all the ones
that'll work
let's see this one now I'm using this
one alright so that kind of leaves this
as being one of the only ones that we
haven't used yet I guess I'm really
hesitant to use it because in some
important parts of the picture are gonna
be cut off but I don't really want to
spend too much time worrying about this
see this one
I don't know if I could get a good crop
on this so that it would work
I guess I might be able to let me
alright let's open this in Pixlr and I
want to double-check the dimensions that
I need
oh yeah XANA I am choosing a header
sorry I didn't I'm in check over there
look Patrick's just got a bunch of
YouTube notifications all at once so
maybe maybe something was happening
Ren's ass how long is this going Ren's a
set of five minutes ago so if you're
still there ends at least this is
probably gonna go till 4:00 maybe later
we'll just see how it goes
Zanna says she does this in [ __ ] yeah I
I actually I do use [ __ ] like for all
the the thumbnails for my videos I do
those in [ __ ] but it's just it's really
convenient for minor things to just open
this in the browser and I I don't have
to worry about having things downloaded
and so this this works for a lot of the
stuff that I normally need to do but I
do like a light [ __ ] I actually had
never used it before and then when I
first started streaming for free code
camp they they have do their thumbnails
in [ __ ] so both sent me both who does
the JavaScript video sent me the
template file so I had to learn how to
use [ __ ] but he was really cool about it
he actually he made a tutorial video for
me so that I could learn how to edit
things in [ __ ] so that was super helpful
and it was really nice of him I could
even hear like his kids were in the
background and stuff so he took time out
of his out of this time with his family
to do the tutorial so those are really
good guy if you get a chance to watch
this videos check them out let's see
sorry my other screen I'm going through
my files trying to find where my there
we go
where these images are so that I can
figure out what I need
okay it looks like I need 2,000 by 500
yeah
all right so 2,000 by 500 what I need so
let's adjust the image size
okay so we're already at two thousand
that's great now we just need to crop
500 out of here foot size okay
mmm Wow all right so I guess I'll try to
get this this cross this is a cool spot
on campus they call it the Rosary circle
so they actually have the same number of
like bushes around here as there are
beads on a rosary so that's kind of cool
I had never knew that I had seen this
for years and never realized that that's
what it was until I started actually
started working here but that's what it
is that's kind of cool it's easier to
tell like from an aerial shot than when
you're actually walking around it
alright I think that's
that'll probably be about what we want
all right so let's save this and use
title
know what an error card
come on I don't want to save it's a
Google Drive let's try to save it maybe
that's why the error occurred that's
kind of a really big file I if I have
time I need to compress these images
there's some other images on the site
that I really want to cut down as well
all right now let's try this out so
where we had news where its title how
did I have this
I'm not even sure if I'm still using
this maybe I am news yeah this was this
is kind of a mess I really wanted to be
able to just pass this in as a prop but
I guess you can't do that if you're
using the style JSX so so that's why I
have this which seems crazy but it's
because I couldn't pass it as a prop and
I'm sure if I would have thought about
it longer I could have figured out some
way to make it work but for now that's
that's just how it is let's go back here
and see that's really weird why did that
happen okay sometimes when I do it just
does like a hot reload the styles that
are in the dish style JSX tags don't get
applied let's go back to our news page
yeah
so maybe it's not that's not where
hmm
then I'm not change the right spot let's
see
all right so yeah this is entitle the
title component and C News News title
okay oh I know what I didn't put it in
the new folder I put it right in the
image folder mm-hm
still not working
let's make sure that this is actually
called news
maybe I didn't put in news
okay yes I've given the ID courses here
to Maine so maybe I just didn't do that
for news yet
there we go all right great okay so we
have that section all right as I move
that around that's not bad I mean this
no one's gonna have a screen like this
I'm not worried about it but let's maybe
see how it looks on this screen okay
that's I can I can live with that
so on most screen dimensions you can see
you can still see the cross there I
think they'll be happy with that awesome
so yeah that definitely took longer than
I hoped it took a bit longer than the
one half but some let's go ahead and
commit commit to change
my livestream on Instagram stopped so I
did it yesterday I think Instagram has a
one hour time limit it seems like
because I've been streaming for one hour
so good to know and yesterday I didn't
realize you could do this but you can
make your livestream available for 24
hours so I did do that so in case
anybody does want to see it it's
available it will be available for the
next 24 hours so I'm trying to find my
there it is my console
whoa you sir okay that's our new file
great
all right great so that's done I'm gonna
say I'm gonna just round this up and say
that this did take one it almost took
one
or maybe yeah I didn't do a whole lot of
looking at the live chat so I could
could knock some time off for that but I
think that took about one alright let's
make news page alright so basically for
this one I just want to clean up the
page a little bit display what needs to
be displayed this is no longer on hold
let's see I want to briefly look through
some of my I can't find it I had open my
oh there we go my messages from my boss
just to get through really quickly and
see if the information that I needed was
there no I don't think it is
all right so I guess I could check my
email quickly too if you remember I said
there there was some extra information
that could go here for some new posts so
I want to find that but it's it's been a
while
yeah oh well it's not a big deal
you know anyone could enter in that
information from WordPress now it'll all
get pulled in it's a wordpress so
that'll be fun let's see we do need to
check these out we need to edit these
pages a bit I don't want the title to
appear like this because if if you get a
long title for a post it looks really
weird and it extends out so it's just
we're gonna change up how this the
single news page works but for now I
want to check out why I'm not getting
the excerpt to display here and I guess
it's not we don't really need it a
hundred percent but usually that's
something that's kind of expected
all right so let's see what we're doing
here
okay so we're not we're not sending the
excerpt in and let's see what it looks
like on and WordPress
all right so this is all the information
I'm getting I'm putting in there in
WordPress
okay so this explains why we have no
content because right now all we have is
the excerpt and we have nothing in the
actual content we also have no
categories yet
see
which I think of the best thing to do
okay let's see I'm gonna do my my short
break here and check the live chat
that'll give me a minute to think about
what I want to do with this I'm gonna
record what I did on my other screen
here
all right so I'm go back to the live
chat Wow still only nine viewers
yeah it must maybe it didn't alert
people
haha yeah you get Patrick must have
heard the Bell the three o'clock Bell
for for prayer time
okay Umberto says that he never received
an alert either hmm that must have been
the problem then for some reason the
alert did not go out that this would be
this would be live so oh well I'm gonna
double-check one more time let's see
promotion promote on my channel page
hmm
yeah yeah all the settings are the same
as I normally do
mm-hmm okay so Joseph said he didn't get
an alert either Umberto said looking at
the alert option for this channel it
looks like he got reset to off that's
odd
did get the alert okay so when I did I
did do a stream earlier on my own my own
channel and Joseph said he did get that
alert okay that must be it then not
really sure what I can do about that
maybe later on I could try to look it up
see if that's happened to anyone else
before so I'm not if it if it keeps
happening then I'll be a little bit more
worried about it but I guess it'll be
not that worried if it just happens the
one time
okay let's sum so yes there's not
there's not that much going on in the
live chat so I don't I'll be right on
time usually I always go over my
allotted time for checking the live chat
at this time I don't think I will
okay
I think I probably will try to end this
stream at like 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time at
the latest because my the head of my
department did want to kind of just meet
and have me give her like a recap of
what I did with this site so I want to
make sure I finish up the stream before
she for she wants to do that so she
actually she might be stopping by my
office in a little bit for that so just
to let you all know probably would be at
most two hour stream all right so my
thoughts were basically it doesn't even
make sense to have these right now be
late
you know cuz right now you know the the
point of these is just to be basically
links with with a little bit of text to
you know right here so they're not even
really meant meant to be like blog post
oh I just had an idea
all right here's what I'm thinking so
right now these link to other places
mostly I think within the site some of
them to external places so what if when
this option was checked
if this is check that it's supposed to
appear on a home page only then instead
of only appearing on the home page it
could also appear here but when you
click the link it would go to the place
would that be too confusing since this
is apparently a blog page
I don't know maybe I shouldn't so my
original thought was that if something
was basically not really a blog post it
was just meant to link somewhere and
then this would be checked and it would
only show up on the home page and not
back here the problem then is that right
now we only have things like that we
don't have any legitimate posts
yeah I think I'll just go with that so
here's what's gonna here's what I'm
gonna do
I'll check the live chat in a second to
see if anyone is kind of has any opinion
on this but what I'm gonna do is at
least for now I'm just gonna put some
test data in here just to see how this
looks and if it looked okay I'm gonna
just have it so that if it's checked if
this box is checked for homepage only it
won't show up here and they'll just have
to put in you know put in things that'll
show up at some point all right so let's
go into yeah we'll do it we'll go to the
news page and let's see if those content
render it let's go so we have this is
okay
see how do I have this listed excerpt I
think I'm going to grab this excerpt and
make it what appears here below below
this date so there's just a very short
description
so I need to pull in
I think that's probably what it is find
out in a second
okay
all right it's not bad
that's pretty good I'm not sure about
the dates I don't know what do you think
about how the date looks to me at Denise
I need to do something with it
alright I'm gonna check the live chat
quickly see what you all think
okay all right so
looks like looks like some people are
saying if I don't have any content leave
these in or potentially I could just put
in some message saying there's no
content if there's nothing I think I'll
end up doing that saying there's no
content just because I think that's
going to be easier than trying to change
with these link - I don't know maybe
about the same but I just kind of don't
want I don't want to make it so these
link to internal pages I want to keep
this as like a normal blog would
function oops
oh cool yeah Patrick just like this
Patrick made some fireworks
Foofa which a lot really cool I like
that that looks really cool I'm gonna
show my kids that they will love that I
feel like I could spent so much time
just watching that I need to like I need
to minimize that quickly before I get
any more distracted thanks for sharing
that Patrick that was cool
okay Umberto's says with the date-style
thinking maybe like a lower color loaf
yeah maybe yeah let's just let's open up
dev tools here and just play around a
little bit see what how we can give it a
look
hmm
Oh
see
okay I could do the gold color and see
how that looks
I think this does need some padding
what is going on
ha letting me to look at the live shed I
know you all caught what I was doing and
now I feel like an idiot because I can't
tell right from left
all right
I think that looks a little better
you seem like here that this extends
beyond you know where the title is so I
wanted to line those up
all right I'm I'm satisfied with that I
think this is one of those things right
I could spend a long time like changing
one pixel here and there but I don't I
don't know that it would be worth it
so let's use this
this was a spin
I think I can actually just say span I
don't have any other spans here and for
some reason things that I pull in from
the API that the styles that are in here
don't get applied to that or at least
they haven't been making they're
supposed to and I'm doing something
wrong
oops
all right let's see if that works yep
great
all right so that works
now let's take a look at this interior
page
and let me before I commit this I'm
gonna look at the live chat just in case
I missed something
okay Santa's and give something like
read more yeah we could have something a
little link that says read more made
throughout
we could have that I am I don't know
what do you think do you think I should
have that is that necessary throughout
the site anytime that there's text in
red it's a link so I mean we do have at
least a pattern of things in in red
being links I don't let me know what you
think if if I really should put a read
more link you know here that people can
click on
okay
all right so
all right so maybe I should put in a
read more link all right let's do that
let's put a read more link in and so
that would be
because here we'll put a span and now
I'm gonna have to do
maybe I'll just I'll leave this a span
or I have the same styling as the date
let me see
because for now I think that'll be okay
so I am gonna make this a link but for
now I just want to see what it looks
like
hmm
so definitely have to
let's see
all right see Alex
all right that's not bad what do you
think
whoa saying there are two live streams
now for free code camp yeah I've never
seen that before either let me check
that out
okay it looks like from the channel it
looks like that though isn't live but he
did put a video up
yeah an hour ago okay
okay so it was just delayed okay cool
hey John how's it going glad you could
join us and thanks for that SVG I'm
gonna try to get that in if I can if I
have time today I really appreciate that
Blake thanks for watching I'm not sure
that I've seen you in the live chat
before if I if you have been in the live
chat and I just didn't remember I'm
sorry about that but otherwise welcome
and thanks for joining in okay so it
seems like the consensus is that the
read more looks good so let's actually
make it a link now so we can just grab
this
let's see
all right let's see how that up and I
turned it blue it's very very sad
area
okay so that's cool resources yep so
that's working how we wanted to alright
great so that looks good now now I can
commit
okay
all right and our Pomodoro session is
almost up and let's see single news page
that was what we're gonna move on to let
me add on let's see alright so I mean
we've we have actually completed this
according to what this task was but I'm
just gonna lump in the changing that
single news page as well I don't want
them don't want to make another card I
have some time left in my estimate so
it's possible that I just have assumed I
was gonna do that as part of this before
I made this so long ago I really can't
looks like I added this card to ready
for development on May 10 so I do know
how long ago I actually made the card
let's see a short break alright I think
actually so think I'm actually I'm gonna
go to the live chat answer some
questions and then probably I'm gonna
finish up then so I don't really want to
start another Pomodoro cycle and another
thing because then that'll put me over
the the two-hour mark for this video so
I do want to leave time to to wrap wrap
up what I'm doing and then meet with my
department head and give an overview of
what all was done and I think I just got
a text from my wife a few minutes ago
that
she has to do something at 4:30 yeah so
I've never I'm gonna answer some
questions and wrap it up and then call
my wife to figure out if if that if the
text she just sent me means that I need
to be home very soon or what so I'm not
sure with them he's but yeah let me
check in the live chat here and see if
I've missed anything I know there's not
a whole lot of people here I'm like
somewhat afraid that everybody's going
to get a delayed notification for this
and right when I'm about to end the
stream
you know everybody will join in at that
point because they will have just gotten
the notification so I kind of hope that
doesn't happen I'd hate to bail on
everybody right away all right so let me
let's see what's in the chat here
okay Susanna mentioned the read more
link could actually make the the text
like drop down and it just pushes
everything else down but it would no
longer up in a new post so I do I like
Patrick says he likes that idea as well
but so right now what will end up
happening is that assuming that the
people put inputting data follow what
the instructions I'm gonna give them so
I'm gonna make them a video to go
through all of this you know how to how
to update all content in WordPress and
how it will look I am gonna say you know
make sure if you don't have a lot of
content you check the box so that it
won't appear on the the news page and
that way I will avoid having a page
that's just mostly blank but I do want I
like the idea of the accordion except I
want people to be able to link directly
to a blog post so especially like to
share it on social media or something
and for that it needs to have its own
page I mean potentially it could do like
some sort of like hash at the end of the
URL but but then you know you still
wouldn't get the data being pulled into
social media properly so I think it
should have its own page and just
hopefully they take my advice and only
make a full page you know post
I'm gonna recommend that every like
legitimate blog post needs to have at
least 300 words that's usually when I
use I used to do a lot of search engine
optimization like copywriting and so
like ghost blogging and things for
companies and I always said like every
post needs to be at least 300 words I
didn't want it to appear to be like
shallow content so that's that's what
I'm gonna recommend okay I see as Anna
says if it's a longer post it could open
a new post so it could be either or I
yeah I do like that idea I'm probably
not gonna do it just because at this
point I'm running out of time
so I'll probably just keep it as is for
now
okay so food says awesome work Jessie
thanks I appreciate that and thanks for
joining in the the live chat thanks for
watching
Blake s what's the link for the timer
it's just tomato timer comm see if I can
yeah so tomato timer com tomato - timer
comm yeah no problem
pooch says what advice would you give to
someone who's learning wordpress along
with code yeah that's actually kind of
how I learned I would say this
definitely seems to be like a wordpress
way of doing things and that's I mean in
terms of they have like these these
hooks and everything is done through
that so in terms of like how you write
PHP I guess just be aware that the
WordPress way of doing it isn't you know
that's specific to WordPress and that
isn't used everywhere so just kind of be
aware of that and then I would you know
when you can do projects that don't
involve WordPress you know try that
because there's a lot of things that
WordPress does for you that if you're
gonna do a project from scratch you know
you need to worry about so things like
like routing WordPress does that for you
but you know normally if you're doing a
project just from scratch with just
JavaScript you'd have to come up with
some sort of routing system like
templating so there's just so many
built-in things with WordPress that if
you only stuck with WordPress you
wouldn't even realize what goes into
that or how to do that so that would be
my advice is I think WordPress is great
it lets you build nice-looking really
nice-looking sites you know really
functional sites without having to worry
so much about all
other stuff and without really having to
know about back-end things but if if you
really want to kind of learn how
everything works then I would try to do
some things not in WordPress and it'll
just give you a much better idea of what
goes in and you will you'll actually
appreciate everything that WordPress
does for you so that's that's kind of my
my advice and also like learn how to use
some of the build tools that you would
use normally on a JavaScript project
that you wouldn't normally use with
WordPress so I'm talking about like you
know using let's say like gulp or web
pack or something
all from the you know learning how to
use the command line using git I think
those sort of things are they're not
used as commonly with WordPress because
you don't you can start up a wordpress
site without that and you can work on it
without it so it's not quite as common
but I think those are important things
to know so that would be my advice
hopefully that helped a bit
okay so John actually said it was a very
delayed notification you know I'm gonna
have to really be more disciplined about
scheduling the time for the video
earlier in the day usually what I what
I've done is like I just put it off
until later on and then that gives me a
better idea of what I'm actually going
to be working on so I can I can write a
better description for the video but I
think maybe it would be better to maybe
my my titles and descriptions aren't
quite accurate but if I were to let's
say it like you know maybe 9:00 9:00
a.m. you know Eastern Time or 10 I would
have the video already scheduled and it
would already be notifying maybe maybe
then there'd be a better chance of the
notifications coming maybe when I wait
till the last minute it's just you know
that's causing the delay I don't really
know I mean you would think that you
could start the stream you know and then
a minute later the notification would go
out but maybe that's it so I'm gonna
make a better effort to not wait until
the last minute get the stream schedule
and then because I usually know like as
soon as I get into work I have a decent
idea of whether or not I'll be able to
stream at the proper time you know 2
p.m. Eastern so I should be able to
schedule and if I have to change it
later on that I do change it but maybe
that will help
okay so Patrick says that he thinks that
the 300 word count for search engine
optimization is outdated and it's
actually longer now okay that's good to
know
okay Zanna says like 500 words maybe
I'll recommend 500 then I think to
recommend I'll go ahead and recommend
about 500 I was just thinking I don't
want to make it too daunting of a task
for them but then on second thought I I
thought you know throughout this entire
process for the site I kept on saying it
would be better if we had less text so I
kind of think it's not really gonna be a
problem for them to hit that 500 word
count since they seem to be going over
the amount of text that I that I think
they should have in most of the other
parts of the site so thanks for that
I'll go with 500 words I haven't done
like real SEO work in so long and that
feel it changes so often that I don't
really feel confident that I'm up on the
latest things I'm sure there's probably
some fundamental things that pretty much
stay the same and I'd be good with that
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say that I'm
nearly as knowledgeable about current
trends and SEO as I used to be used to
be I used to be able to get sites to the
you know right to the top of the first
page and in small markets
you know usually within you know within
months I could I could for sure get him
up I had like I had like a plan and if
you just stuck to the plan you know it
seemed like it always worked
like I said in small markets not in like
high competition places but usually like
when that starts happening and you can
continually consistently get sites
ranked higher with the formula then
things change the algorithms changed and
I wasn't like spamming bad content my my
philosophy and
when copywriting was always yes you want
to do it so you can get ranked higher
but I always wanted to give users
something useful to them and meaningful
even if my main purpose in writing is
just to get you know more to get rank
higher and the search engine rankings
then I still wanted to provide some
benefit so I think that's really what
it's about is if you provide something
beneficial and substantial consistently
then eventually you will rank higher as
long as you're doing the fundamental
things like you know you have your HTML
formatted properly and things like that
title tags title tags always found to be
really important I assume they're still
important
all right Gaurav says looks good man
thanks thanks I appreciate that
yeah then I said I hope they won't ask
you to write their content - yeah it
definitely won't be I don't write
content anymore I'm not really it's I'm
not into that so I I do not offer that
service to clients anymore yeah so
there's a dimension since they expect
design tests from you yeah I still I do
design and that's out of necessity
because there's no one else that can do
design but we have we have we actually
have writers on staff in my department
so since we have writers we have graphic
designers but they just stick with print
stuff mostly so and we have writers but
we don't have a web designer so I end up
doing the web design as well
yeah John says it's hard to convince
people to have good and relevant tax
count on websites everyone wants to go
for the minimalist white-on-white look
yeah I mean I like minimalist in general
but I do you you need to have a certain
word count I think on on a page but
there were some pages where I kept I
wanted to keep a large font size so I'm
convinced that the one of the keys to
having people actually read your content
is to have a decent sized font so like
I'm not really comfortable going below
like 18 pixels for most font sizes
because it's just hard to read I mean it
really it depends on your screen and how
far away you are from your screen
different things like that but basically
like I'm way less likely to read
something if the font is small and I
have to like really focus on it and I
have I have good vision I've good
eyesight you know I'm young so I can
imagine people who have difficult you
know they don't have good vision or
they're older like it's got to be
terrible for them to try to read this
small font so having said that if you're
gonna go with a large font you have to
cut down the amount of text otherwise it
just seems like an overwhelming amount
of text because you have this large font
size now so I like to increase font size
decrease the amount of text and then
it'll be easier for people to read and
there'll be less that they have to read
so it's more likely that they'll read a
higher percentage of the content on
every page so I think that's my
philosophy on things maybe I may be
mistaken but
see
all right cool yeah so John mentioned
the Meta Description tag is ignored by
search engine yeah so if you're still
using the Meta Description tag on your
site just stop it's not used by search
engines well I shouldn't say stop here's
my feeling that Meta Description tag if
you don't use it a search engine will
just pull content from your site anyway
and it'll probably be relevant and it'll
match up with whatever the search term
was so you can add it if you really want
to specify what the description would be
but it's totally not necessary so I
guess it just depends on what you want
I've gone back and forth on it sometimes
depending on whether you know depending
on what I want so if you have a certain
like marketing message that you really
want to appear then I guess you use use
it otherwise like don't worry as much
about it because the search engine will
pull what they want
yeah Johnson yeah thanks for clarifying
yeah I didn't mean let me clarify that
because I don't mean so John is rightly
bringing up that it's the the meta or
the keywords so like the meta keywords
are not crawled like so those won't be
called the description will they'll see
the description another use of
description but it won't count in terms
of your your ranking so it's it's not
like it's invisible to search engines
but it won't like don't keywords stuff
your description right because that's
not going to do anything for you in
terms of search ranking right your
description in a way that's going to
appeal to your users okay don't don't
consider search engines when you're
doing your description does that make
more sense
I probably shouldn't talk about SEO at
all anyway since I'm not I'm not really
up on it so like I said I haven't done
anything with search engine optimization
in probably two years so don't don't
take what I say as as accurate anymore
but I think it's it's been true for a
long time so it's true to say don't use
meta keywords if you do use the Meta
Description write it to your users don't
worry about search engines because they
won't use that as a ranking factor the
title tag is important to have the
proper wording in because at least it's
been my experience that the title tag is
actually very important in terms of what
keywords you actually rank for and your
header tags alright so I'm not I'm not
gonna comment any more on on search
engine optimization because I I think
saying less is better at this point
because I don't want to mess any one
site up by giving incorrect advice on on
that but I'm thinking I'm gonna I'm
gonna wrap up this stream thanks for
watching like I said I'm gonna try to
schedule the streams earlier so you all
can get hopefully get the notifications
on time and not late so I apologize for
that I hadn't anticipated that that
would happen I'm not entirely sure why
it happened but just in case it was
because of the timing of me starting
scheduling the stream I'll try to do it
earlier so tomorrow I will be back with
an entirely new project I'm not exactly
sure what it'll be but it'll be new so
thank you so much to everyone who helped
out with this project I think it turned
out really well and way better with your
help than it ever could have been with
just me working on it I really
appreciate that and yeah I think that's
that's it for today's stream see
tomorrow and have a great day